geheimnisvoll
schön durchgesetzt
morbid
die düstere gothic szene ist nicht
jedermanns sache
ihre schon mitra devi schneidet gerade
ihren neuen dokumentarfilm gothic über
fünf schweizer anhänger dieser kultigen
bewege sich immer wieder mit abgründigen
und deshalb bewegt sich mitra devi am
liebsten in welten am rande der
gesellschaft wie hier bei den gothics an
ihrem jährlichen viktorianischen
picknick in leipzig
den mystischen 10 suchern fühlt sich die
50-jährige eng verbunden
die meisten modelle szene wand ihre
abgründe auch nach außen zeigen ob
mitleidig zum beispiel auf grün teil ich
mit ihnen aber ich musste sie sich nicht
unbedingt zeigen
ich sehe kein vollgas ich finds habe ich
mit schwarz weiß mittlerweile ist mitra
devi weit über ihre heimatstadt zürich
hinaus bekannt für ihre hochklassigen
krimis mit dem authentischen
lokalkolorit schon im kindergarten fiel
sie mit schaurigen erzählungen auf ich
wähle ich lachte liebesroman autorin
oder heimatroman schriftstellerinnen das
museum abgrund gesprungen und
untergründig ist auch der kunde
2001 veröffentlichte sie ihre ersten
kurzgeschichten inzwischen erschienen 14
bücher darunter einige schwarze morgue
perlen die auch als shrek memphis im
radio gesendet wurden
hinter ihrem schaffen steht ein
persönliches schlüsselerlebnis mit
seinem taxi in italien und in bologna
xiii und bin ganz kurz nach dem
bombenattentat am bahnhof von 70 oder 80
tote verursacht hat bin ich auch und
polizeiführer überdeckt die körper und
wurde ein riesen aufruhr und gewiss
nicht so knapp und
mit wasser schrieb ich eigentlich heißt
so als autobiografisch aber sicher hat
alles was ich schreibe erspart wurde ich
mich identifizieren
natürlich auch lotte sind immer erlaubt
und hat eigentlich abgelehnt wurde habe
treffer 24 bin wo ich wohne in dem sie
nutzen zumal bistros machen aber der
neue mini geschichten in der jüngst ihre
krimis plant und recherchiert sie -
davon zeugt der dokumentarfilm der sie
bei der entstehung ihres preisgekrönten
romans blut feinde begleitet darin geht
es um einen banküberfall mit geiselnahme
und verfolgungsjagd
zwei weitere einsatzwagen mit je vier
mann brauchen hinter ihnen die
möglichkeit zeichen die bank über das
lenkrad nach links krimis begegnen ihr
auf schritt und tritt
ich so zu mir oder senioren bahnhof
stadelhofen vor der sv rust der
bayerischen sache über gurken und
tomaten mann scheint die später und den
amis ausprobiert es herrschte völlige
dunkelheit wo zum teufel waren
irgendjemand hatte ihn mit einem harten
gegenstand niedergeschlagen
dann über das schwarz um ihn geworden
also herrin über leben und tod sie im
krimi gib mir das mit dem singen macht
gefühl aber es gibt eine frechheit dass
ich geschichten erfinden figuren
kreieren schicksal eigentlich um leben
und tod geht es auch in ihren bildern
wallach unziemlich stand jetzt ein
klischeehaft aber unser buch geplant und
vor spezielle hans binders bild vor dem
monitor aber als früheste von anderen
ort als das mit mord mitra devi spiel
mit den dunklen seiten des lebens bietet
wohliger schauer und modisch unter
mit schlaflosen nächten ist zurecht
merkte dass sich seine hände nicht